tonight in Berkeley be there or be
square we will be live broadcasting the
entire thing and I'll give you the
update plus president Trump uh he just
made a deal with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer on the border or did he but yeah
he sort of did we'll talk about all of
those things plus we'll do a little bit
about Big Ideas on today's Ben Shapiro
show I am Ben Shapiro it's a day of joy
to take a fun it's a day of laughter for
everyone yes I'm going to Berkeley this
afternoon so that will be a party and
I'm about to give you the update on that
I have to say for little old me they are
doing a fair bit of security work it's
pretty amazing I have some video of it
that I want to show you and I also want
to give you the full analysis of Donald
Trump doing what those of us who always
thought he was going to do you know this
actually he did it okay so finally we've
been saying for a year that Donald Trump
was never going to really build this
wall that the wall was basically
something he was just saying during the
campaign he build sections of the wall
that it was all just to campaign slogan
that he was shouting and now it appears
he cut a deal with Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer to legalize the dreamers
and not get funding for the border wall
so Magga mega mega mega mega okay so
we'll get to all of that but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so do you feel
uncertain about the world if you don't
it's because you're stupid you should
feel uncertain about the world because
the world is in uncertain place and in
these perilous times whether it's
natural disasters or whether it is
terrorist attacks or whether it is just
the vagaries of politics it is possible
that your stocks are going to get hit
and that's why you need to put some of
your money in precious metals everyone
should have at least some of their money
in precious metals you should diversify
that's what Birch Gold is for right now
if you go to birchgold.com slash been
you can contact Birch gold group and
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals it's a 16 page
kit it shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of risky
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA to get that kit go to
birchgold.com slash been birchgold.com
slash men they're the people that I
trust to invest in precious metals
they've a long-standing track record of
success with thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews in
an A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau they're the people that I would
trust
birchgold.com / bending at that
comprehensive 16 page free-kick okay so
I'm gonna get to trump and Schumer and
Pelosi the happy gang the bunch of
buddies we'll get to them in just one
second but first I'm gonna give you the
update on Berkeley so it is now obvious
that the police are expecting some bad
stuff to happen there apparently two
protests they're supposed to happen
tomorrow at Berkeley Oh today Berkeley
rather one is the one is a protest
directed against yours truly and the
other is directed against the police
themselves which should be a lot of fun
here are some of the the tape of the
preparations that are being made for
security over in Berkeley this evening
from the local news if you can't see
they're literally setting up k-bar in
front of the in front of Zell Urbach
Hall which is where I'm going to be
speaking they were doing this in the
middle of the night saying up these
cement barriers they were doing this for
blocks around apparently they're
blocking off a main street in Berkeley
today all for me and I understand I'm a
physically imposing specimen but still
it seems a little weird listen I guess
that if you if you use Democrat
Keynesian economics then you have to
acknowledge I'm creating more jobs in
Berkeley than the current mayor of
Berkeley
look at this I'm creating infrastructure
jobs just by just by visiting I'm
creating infrastructure jobs Berkeley is
saying that for upcoming security events
my event the free speech week that's
happening next week they're spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
security all because an Tifa is insane
and because leftists are totally crazy
so the good news is that Berkeley looks
like they're taking seriously the
security issue the bad news is that
Berkeley is gonna build a wall before
Trump does like long before Trump does
because the other big news today is that
President Trump appears to have cut a
deal when Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
over deca that would be President
Obama's executive amnesty so here is
what Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer said
yesterday after emerging from a meeting
with President Trump okay this is their
their press release we had a very
productive meeting at the White House
with the president the discussion
focused on taka we agreed to enshrine
the protections of daca into law quickly
and to work out a package of border
security excluding the wall that's
acceptable to both sides we also urge
the
to make permanent the cost-sharing
reduction payments and those discussions
will continue that that last is a
reference to Obamacare it was
acknowledged last night in little on
really little covered news that Trump
was looking to move toward fixing
Obamacare rather than repealing and
replacing it that went by the wayside
because everybody is very upset over the
the amnesty stuff and what they are
talking about here is amnesty and even
from most ardent allies are really
ticked about it so the headline last
night over a Breitbart was amnestied on
amnesty Dawn five seconds ago Steve
Bannon was saying that he was Trump's
most ardent ally now it's amnesty dawn
and Colts are the author of the these
bestseller in Trump We Trust
now tweets quote at this point who
doesn't want Trump impeached that's a
rather abrupt about-face even Sean
Hannity
was was saying that this is not a good
deal for Trump he of course put blame
Paul Ryan in Mitch McConnell because
that's the way that this works basically
a lot of I will say a solid number of
people in Trump's base have turned into
from Blazing Saddles and if
they're mad and they're mad they just
punch a horse and the horse happens to
be Mitch McConnell or Paul Ryan and
these tweets I mean here's what Sean
tweeted if reports true 100% I blame
Republicans they caused this they wanted
him to fail and now pushed him into the
arms of political suicide if true so let
me get this straight they stood up to
Obama's executive amnesty for years and
held it up in the courts but Trump
making a deal with the Democrats is
their fault because mega-mega underwater
chess backgammon Mick Hungry Hungry
Hippos magda and then he says weak
Republicans have betrayed voters POTUS
needs to stay the course and keep his
promises or it's over Pelosi and Schumer
can never be trusted okay I think you
never be trusted then why is Trump
making these moves so Pelosi what's
really funny about this is is that Trump
obviously desires the love and respect
of a lot of people on the left and he
thinks he can earn it by giving them
what they want Nancy Pelosi yesterday
was ripping into Trump and basically
comparing him to FDR
in turning Japanese people during World
War two she was doing this and five
seconds later Trump was cutting a deal
with her so we can have four guys in
Chicago and I saw this art exhibit that
I was invited to see it's called and
then they came for
me and it's about the internment of the
Japanese American Patriots in our
country who were interred in and turned
into camps during World War two while
their family members were fighting for
freedom for America and for the world in
World War two
they were in camps and they came for me
and now they're coming for the dreamers
okay so she was saying this five minutes
ago then she goes to the White House and
she convinces Trump because he's a big
heart for the dreamers as we know that
she has to cut a deal with him the only
leverage Trump has to get his border
wall funded is this this is his leverage
okay it's not like there are lots of
opportunities for him to use his
leverage in the future I know there are
a lot of folks who are big Trump fans
Bill Mitchell big Trump fan saying well
we just have to wait for him to
negotiate he is already not funded the
border wall in the in the 1.1 trillion
dollar budget he signed earlier this
year he did not attempt to fund the
border wall in raising the debt ceiling
he did not attempt to fund the border
wall in extending the budget for another
three months he is now not attempting to
fund the border wall in daca
so where exactly is his leverage where
the leverage go the answer is there is
no leverage the border wall appears to
have been largely BS it's sort of like
Obama saying that he's gonna close down
Gitmo and then never closing down Gitmo
and Trump is is basically so initially
after all of this broke last night the
White House said hey we didn't reach a
deal okay we didn't reach a deal trumpet
he may have talked about this stuff with
Pelosi and Schumer but we definitely did
not make a deal along these lines then
Trump got up and he started tweeting
mm-hmm here's what he tweeted no deal
was made last night on taka massive
border security would have to be agreed
to in exchange for consent would be
subject to vote okay well but wait a
second you said there was no deal
reached and then the next the exact next
sentence you say massive border security
would have to be agreed to not a wall
massive border security so that's
exactly what Schumer and Pelosi said
then he said this is really amazing the
wall which is already under construction
in the form of new renovation of old and
existing fences and walls will continue
to be built
that's not building the wall that's
renovating existing fences I don't
remember the the large crowds of people
chanting
build the new renovation of old an
existing fences in walls build the new
renovation of old an existing fences and
walls now admittedly it's a bit of a
mouthful but that's not what they're
chanting and Trump himself said during
the campaign he used build the wall as
his go-to he he said this openly in
interviews he's headed to the New York
Times he said you know when my crowd
gets bored all I have to do is they
build the wall and they go crazy they go
crazy so there's always a slogan
then from starts going full-on lefty
okay here's what he says he says does
anybody really want to throw out good
educated and accomplished young people
who have jobs some serving in the
military really um you five seconds ago
five seconds ago a lot of members of
your base five seconds ago okay Donald
Trump campaigned on this he kept saying
we're either haven't we that have a
country or we don't right I mean you
remember this you were here
okay the gas lighting is so irritating
the gas lighting is so stupid we were
all here we were all present we were all
accounted for okay we were all watching
this it was the most-watched election in
American history we all remember what
you said but now Trump is swiveling
about-face and then he says they've been
in our country for many years through no
fault of their own brought in by parents
at young age plus big border security
okay he should finish this by saying
please clap okay this is low-energy Jeb
okay they should put an exclamation
point a wilting exclamation point after
Trump's name because of this this is
this is exactly Jeb's Bush's policy like
word-for-word jeb Bush's policy and jeb
Bush's defense of the policy it was
Marco Rubio's policy hey Donald Trump
spent four years ripping Rubio and Jeb
and even Cruz you guys are not
sufficiently tough on border security
and then he walks across the aisle and
talks in Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
and people are blaming Ryan and
McConnell for this somehow and maybe
Donald Trump is one not a very good
negotiator and two desperately wants the
approval of Democrats because he's sort
of a career Democrat maybe that's the
problem here okay not that anybody could
predict it anything like this or
anything I mean who could have possibly
predicted that this would actually be
the sort of thing that he would do I
mean who could have predicted that this
would be his immigration policy I'll
tell you who could have predicted it in
just one second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so are you a professional
who's looking to
resume matters you want to add some
impressive skills do you want to launch
that side business or pick up a new
passion project that's what skills chair
is for Skillshare is an online learning
community with over 17,000 classes and
design business and more you can learn
everything from logo design to social
media marketing to street photography
unlimited access to all of this for one
low monthly price you never pay per
class again so I personally have been
looking at the Skillshare class I told
you I took a watercolor class now I'm
taking a google analytics class because
I'd like to see how analytics works
better all of these are done in in
bite-sized increments so you really get
a lot of information out of a short
period of time and as I say they have a
wide variety of classes that makes you
an expert in whatever field you choose
to enter ok skills show right now is
giving my listeners a month of unlimited
access absolutely free so you can go and
check it out see if you like it you will
go to Skillshare comm slash Shapiro that
Skillshare comm slash up arrow to redeem
your free month okay again Skillshare
comm slash capiro and you redeem your
free month there I mean the list of
classes is virtually endless and it is
all great stuff I mean it's a to be an
expert on a particular topic requires
that you know a little bit about it and
Skillshare can make you an expert on a
number of topics it's just terrific
skill shared comm slash then check it
out ok so who could have predicted this
sort of policy who possibly could have
predicted this what would you say if you
knew somebody who'd written in say May
2016 like May 25th 2016 quote a
president Trump wins inside an executive
order to build a wall with Mexico after
being informed by his advisers that such
a wall would actually look more like
sections of barrier punctuated by high
tech touch fences Trump would also
quietly concede who built sections that
resemble a wall mostly for symbolic
purposes Trump would probably staff up
ice but we'd see no mass deportations
who would revoke President Obama's daca
but he would not replace it with a harsh
enforcement operation the costs and
political blowback would be too steep
despite promises to do so Trump would
not romantically curtail the number of
high-tech visas handed out he's made
clear he believes American wages already
too high
Trump would however implement new
restrictions on immigration from Muslim
countries who could have predicted such
a thing can you think of anyone who
would have predicted such a thing say
more than a year ago just by watching
what Trump was saying hmm who here's a
clue it's me okay
this is not hard to predict that's the
point okay this is not me just patting
myself on the back although I do love
doing that the fact is that what
happened here was utterly predictable if
you did not actually want to if you did
not actually want to deceive yourself
here so people who are very disappointed
today it's because you weren't watching
closely I understand you were hopeful
and you can still say look it still
applies better than Hillary still
applies because honest-to-god dog feces
in the presidents who'd be better than
Hillary but that's not the question the
question right now is did Trump just
break his key campaign promise and the
answer is pretty clearly yes I mean
listen to how Trump is talking about
this so Trump is now saying that
everyone agrees on Obama's executive
amnesty I was here when he was saying it
had to go I was here when he used to say
things like America first we either have
a border or we don't people are gonna
have to leave now what's he saying
something completely different
take this and listen what Trump has to
say here we want to get massive border
security and I think that both ng
and just younger I think they agree with
this but so we met last night with as
you know
Pelosi and a whole group and I think
with fairly close but we have to get
massive water to you
oh I think he's gonna 92 percent of the
people agree on daca okay but those
weren't the people who voted for you and
those were the people who you were
saying we're going to we're going to be
pleased with your presidency okay honest
to god if you just read what Trump said
in Obama's voiced its it's totally
Obama's line of thinking right just read
this tweet does anybody really want to
throw out good educated accomplished
young people who have jobs I'm serving
in the military they've been in the
country for many years through no fault
of their own rotten my parents at a
young age we need big border security
for sure but mitch is on board Paul Ryan
is on board we all feel look 92% of
people agree on daca when you read it in
Obama's voice suddenly you start getting
pissed don't you because it's Obama's
policy I do love in that clip where
Trump starts to say Nancy and then he
shifts and realize he shouldn't say
Nancy you should say Pelosi because it
makes him sound like he's getting close
with Chuck and Nancy it's pretty amazing
and then he was asked about this again
and listen to this listen to this this
little lie here here this is pretty
amazing he's asked about amnesty because
this is an amnesty okay guys when you
talk about giving legal citizenship to
all of the people who are here illegally
that is amnesty here is Trump we're not
looking at amnesty we're looking at
allowing people to stay here we're
working with everybody Republican we're
working with Democrat I just spoke with
Paul Ryan he's so important everybody's
on board
they want to do something we're not
talking about amnesty we're not taught
do you get that we're not talking about
amnesty anymore this is exactly what
Marco Rubio used to say is what the gang
of eight used to say it's not amnesty is
to path the legalization I mean they
just get to stay here and never loose
acquaintance under know that amnesty now
Trump says it never oh well I guess if
he says it's not amnesty it says he
should know I mean if it's not amnesty
it's not it don't be a fool of course
it's amnesty and of course Trump was
going to do this and of course from did
do this what does this say it says that
Trump has no principles even the ones
where he was most
rooted to principle were not really his
principles he shifted his immigration
positions a thousand times during this
campaign and before it okay so so anyone
who's surprised by this was was blinding
themselves again this is not a case
against voting for Trump okay that
election is over and I'm very very glad
that Hillary Clinton is not president
which we'll discuss in just a second as
we discussed yesterday but that is not
the same thing as saying that Trump is
some sort of promise keeper that you can
trust to negotiate on behalf of the
people who voted for him because that's
just not true and then people in the
White House are chortling about this
stuff okay Sarah Huckabee Sanders
yesterday at the White House she says
you know Trump's done more for
bipartisanship that Obama ever did
president's negotiating on behalf of the
American people exactly what he was
elected to do and the idea that you guys
keep trying to distort this into a bad
thing is I think exactly why this
president was elected they were sick and
tired of business as usual they wanted
somebody who would break up the status
quo that would bring people from both
sides of the table together to have
conversations this president's done more
for bipartisanship in the last eight
days than Obama did in eight years yes
that's not why he ran we didn't run him
so he could be bipartisan we ran him
because we thought that Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell were a bunch of
weaklings who kept surrendering to the
Democrats okay you don't get to use the
logic Mitch McConnell Paul Ryan those
company cut cut cuts constantly sip
surrendering to the Obama agenda then
Trump gets in there and implements the
Obama agenda you go if those Kuck block
that man if they block that Obama agenda
okay that wasn't even the only bad story
last night from the White House this one
is from the hill president Trump was
open to the idea of IPAB of a bipartisan
Obama care stabilization bill but did
not make any commitments during a
meeting Wednesday with a group of House
lawmakers attendee said the bipartisan
group of lawmakers known as the problem
solvers pitch Trump on their plans to
stabilize Obama care market he was
clearly open to it intrigues had
representative Josh got heimer Democrat
of New Jersey a co-chair of the group
God Hammer said there was some
discussion of the possibility that
Democrats could call the bill fix and
Republicans could call it something else
I'll call it a fix others will call it
what they want but it matters less about
what you call it than what it is
he was very intrigued by that so now
Trump is saying that he'll work with
Democrats to fix Obamacare and then
he'll call it repeal and we'll be told
that if we don't support his fixes to
Obamacare then we are Kooks again
I mean this is it this whole thing is so
annoying Trump on taxes yesterday so he
says he has a tax plan but what is his
talking point on the tax plan that he's
not gonna give a tax cut to the rich
okay let's be fair let's be clear about
something the rich pay the vast majority
of the income tax in the United States
by a long shot by a huge percentage but
here's Trump mimicking the Democratic
talking point we want a 15% rate because
that would bring us low not by any means
the lowest but it would bring us to a
level where China and other countries
are and we will be able to compete with
anybody nobody will be able to touch us
so we would like to see 15%
and by the way lower and lower for
individuals is much lower than that for
individuals and the rich will not be
gaining at all with this plan we're not
look we're looking for the middle class
and we're looking for jobs okay
the rich if you want to cut taxes you
have to cut them on the rich according
to the Tax Foundation and an analysis of
IRS data shows the top one percent of
taxpayers paid forty point four percent
of total income taxes collected by the
federal government the highest
percentage in modern history the bottom
ninety five percent paid thirty nine
point four percent of the income tax
burden you got that the top one percent
paid more in income tax than the bottom
ninety five percent so who the hell you
gonna cut taxes on exactly all of this
is just Democratic talking points
dressed up as populism dressed up as
populism it is not populism okay
populism is just a strategy populism is
not an actual ideology that this whole
thing is is highly annoying it's mostly
annoying because again we were told over
and over and over that Trump was gonna
be a solid conservative one he was in
office or at least if he was gonna be a
populist he was gonna mirror a lot of
conservative talking points instead it
seems like his negotiation strategy at
least in the last couple of weeks has
been surrender whatever you want to the
Democrats if that's gonna be the next
three and a half years boy it's a
problem and I'm not the only one saying
this okay
you know for people who say well you
never liked Trump very much to begin
with Sean Hannity did Laura Ingraham did
Ann Coulter did Breitbart did they are
all saying the same thing that I am
today they're all saying the same thing
that I am because the bottom line is I
expect a Republican to act like a
conservative and so do these people at
least on this issue so it's it's really
irritate now that said I think this does
explain a little bit you know Trump
being who Trump is I think this does
explain a little bit why it is that
Hillary Clinton lost the 2016 election
so she continues her tour of stupidity
she is she's going around whining this
is her new life story I mean I shouldn't
say new she's been doing this entire
career but now she's whining for actual
pay she's going around talking about how
she was jobbed it was just a she wish
she would have won this thing if it
hadn't been for the cruelty of fate oh
no say here's Hillary Clinton saying she
would have been seen as a genius if
she'd won the election well I thought it
was pretty revolutionary that I was
the first woman to have a realistic
chance of becoming president so I don't
know how any woman who is not familiar
to people since we have so many hurdles
to overcome could have even been in that
position that I found myself so if I'd
won you know I would have been seen as a
genius my campaign would have been see
it is perfect I understand all of that I
know if you'd won then you would have
not been considered a genius he would
have been seen as someone who beat the
weakest Republican candidate in the
history of political parties I mean
Donald Trump was running with a 35
percent approval rating and he beat you
ain't no one would've seen you as a
genius it was - you were supposed to win
this race the reason Hillary Clinton's
in this we didn't win this race is
because she's incredibly off-putting and
because she has no capacity toward
introspection at all there's never a
point where she looks inside herself and
goes say I wonder why people don't like
me I wonder instead it's always the
world that's the problem she was asked
yesterday by Matt Lauer did you make
enough mistakes to lose and she says no
of course I didn't make enough mistakes
to lose it was you you evil Americans
use sexist or racist here's Hillary
Clinton looking very much like Veruca
like like the what's that what's it not
Veruca who's a big blueberry in in
willing won't come to Chocolate Factory
in any case here's Hillary Clinton who
slightly resembles a sky-blue blueberry
and on the south mail our there is a lot
of criticism in this book and effort of
full disclosure you criticize me pretty
soundly in a few pages of this book when
it comes to the self-inflicted wounds
when you look at the list of them and
you go through them in the book hmm did
you make enough mistakes yourself to
lose the election without any of the
other things you talked about well I
will say no Matt I don't think that will
surprise you but you know also this book
has a lot of behind the scenes look at
what it's like to run for president
particularly again as a woman okay so I
love that it's all about that that she
didn't make any mistakes right
everything was absolutely perfect
everything was just great it's really
the fault of the Americans and she just
continues doing this this is her tour
now this is her tour okay and I'm gonna
explain why that matters in just one
second why Democrats should look out
because if they think that they can just
campaign against Trump they've got
another
think coming they've got another thing
coming but before I get to that first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over a Beachbody on demand so do you
look at me and say dude that guy's
ripped well if you don't then you should
because I am and also you should go and
you should work out no matter what you
think of me you may think well he seems
kind of scrawny
well that's because you need to work out
more as do i and that's why I use
Beachbody on demand it's an online
fitness streaming service that gives you
unlimited access to a wide variety of
highly effective world-class workouts
personalized to meet your needs plus
extensive nutritional content it's all
geared toward helping people achieve
their health and fitness goals we're
talking familiar brand stuff you already
know peop 90 X 21 day fix t25 three week
yoga retreat right all these brands are
included in the Beachbody on demand
program plus they also can give you
nutrition programs not just the workout
programs when I'm on the road I always
use Beachbody on demand you know when
I'm at home I can go to the gym when I'm
on the road then I need to work out in
my room sometimes and one of the great
things about Beachbody honest man is
they have all of these programs where
you really don't need gear in order for
you to to get fit that's what's great
about Beachbody on demand and they get
there you get your nutrition in line as
well they also include brand new
first-of-its-kind cooking show for
healthy weight loss and portion control
this is called fixate it'll teach you
how to cook healthy delicious and simple
recipes for you and your family they've
over 100 recipe videos to help you cook
healthier because it's not just about
the sort of effort you put into exercise
it's also about the crap you put in your
body make sure that you don't do that
that's what Beachbody Ahn's man is
therefore again my listeners can claim a
free trial membership just text
Shapiro's to 30 30 30
so text the number 30 30 30 text
Shapiro's to 30 30 30 and you get free
access to the entire platform for free
it's a free trial membership so you can
try it out see how much you like it I
promise once you've got it you're never
gonna want to give it up because there's
such a wide variety of programming
you're never gonna get bored and it
really gets you in shape that's always
been my big problem when I workout is
that if I go in and do the same routine
every day I get very bored very easily
with Beachbody on demand you never get
bored because you can use a different
program every time if you want it's
fantastic Beachbody Ahn's man Tex
Shapiro 2 30 30 30 Shapiro 2 30 30 30
and yes I do use Beachbody honest man
very frequently and I do workout
everyday which is why I mean look at
Berkeley look how they're preparing for
me they're afraid I'm gonna walk in
there and I'm just gonna take
iron barriers and fling them she's in
one hand I'm just gonna pick up those
cement K bars and just chuck them it'll
be amazing I mean just watch for it
tonight it'll be unbelievable okay so
the reason that Hillary's awfulness
actually matters is because I think that
this should this should be a warning to
Republicans and Democrats Hillary
Clinton she should be a warning to all
people right she's like Dante seventh
circle of hell abandon all hope all ye
who enter here
but when it comes to Hillary Clinton
what Democrats should realize is that
they can run a candidate just as
charmless as Hillary Clinton and loose
Donald Trump and Republicans should
recognize that Donald Trump is not on a
pathway to victory just because you beat
the least popular Democratic candidate
in the history of American politics
okay the Democratic candidate matters in
other words it's not just about Trump
it's also about who the Democrats run so
and right now what's what's fascinating
is that then the Democrats obviously
think that they've got a no-lose
situation with Trump they think right
now because he's cutting deals he will
continue to be unpopular he won't gain
radically in popularity they can always
shellac him later he'll always be Trump
he'll always make a mistake and so they
may as well get what they can get right
they may as well get a bunch of lefty
policy split the Republican Party create
a civil war this is why Trump needs to
understand that without his base he's
got nothing
okay without his base he doesn't have
the middle he doesn't have the left and
no matter how much he reaches over to
the other side no matter how many New
York Times editorial talk about the new
independent Trump people are not moving
toward him because he's already decided
in the public mind Hillary had the same
problem in this election cycle she kept
trying to redefine herself there is no
way to redefine Hillary Clinton there is
no way to redefine Donald Trump okay so
I want to discuss also the situation
with Jamil he'll choose the the woman on
SportsCenter six sc6 who ripped into
president Trump because this is actually
a story that's now going undercover
because there's so much news but for
that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire and become a subscriber for
$9.99 a month you can be a subscriber to
daily wire it'll make your life
immensely better it will make you you
you will just enjoy it so much okay you
watch my show live you can get it later
without any ads you can watch Andrew
Clavin Stroh live you can watch Michael
Knowles's show live and be part of the
mailbags and then that means mail bags
that we do special like next Tuesday
we're doing a facebook Q&A and you can
ask questions live if you subscribe
that's $9.99 a month before that plus
you get our website without a banner ads
the banner ads just go away which is
pretty cool you get all that plus if you
subscribe annual you got
this the very finest in beverage vessels
okay the pellet with the poisons in the
vessel with the pestle this right here
is better than any of those okay and
this is it's better than the flagon with
the Dragon it's better than the vessel
with the pestle it has the brew that is
true
okay the leftist here is hot or cold
tumbler you get that for just a $99
investment per year the annual
subscription it is it is the greatest
thing that you will ever own and if you
don't understand the reference then go
watch the court jester you film
illiterate okay so if you just want to
listen later go over to SoundCloud or
iTunes hit subscribe alright and and
leave us a review we always appreciate
it plus please go over our YouTube
channel and subscribe there as well we
put up all of my videos over at YouTube
under the daily wire YouTube channel so
please subscribe over there we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so yesterday in a story that has
basically now been eaten completely
eaten by the next news cycle Berkeley
and from in the Trump wall and all this
Jamel Hill was this this commentator who
we talked about yesterday a shoe is a is
a black woman who was who's on sc6
a se6 is not a show I like I do not
enjoy the show I think is a bad show
Michael Smith and Jamel Hill but she
goes on Twitter and she says the Trump
is white supremacist surrounds himself
with white supremacists etc okay it's
basically just warmed over Tana he see
Coates well the White House is asked
about this yesterday and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders says from the podium of the
White House that she should probably be
fired I think that's one of the more
outrageous comments that anyone could
make and certainly something that I
think is for fireable offense by ESPN
okay this is stuff no White House should
say imagine for a second that I said
something on CNN and what said let's
imagine I was a CNN contributor haha and
let's imagine that I was on CNN and I
said something nasty about President
Obama and the Obama White House that
said they should fire him as a
contributor okay that would be wildly
inappropriate government officials
should not be calling for firings of
private individuals based on expression
of opposition to the government's the
two members of the government it's just
it does not come off well it does not
pro First Amendment I don't understand
how you can say that you want Jamel Hill
fired but then say that it's bad if
Brendan Eich over at mozilla firefox'
was fired because he supports
proposition 8 upholding traditional
marriage right it's one or the other
okay you got to say that people either
should not be fired for expressing their
political views or they should be fired
based on you don't like their political
views but I am and there's a lot of talk
about snowflake ray and there should be
right I'm gonna go visit a bunch of
snowflakes up in Berkeley today but
snowflake we exist on both sides if
you're that offended by Jamel Hill I
recommend that you get a life
hey Jamel hello said some stuff I don't
agree with the stuff that she says lots
of people say stuff that I don't agree
with she not only has a right to say it
she's basically given free rein by ESPN
that the people here who I think are the
biggest hypocrites are ESPN I think yes
PN is absurd ESPN is willing to get rid
of Mike Ditka get rid of Curt Schilling
for no apparent reason except that they
are conservative but Jamel Hill they
issue a statement about how they don't
like her politics and then they don't
suspend her the double standard is
telling
but the solution to that is not Jamel
Hill being fired it's ESPN hiring people
like Mike Ditka and Kurt Schilling and
Rush Limbaugh by the way instead of
doing this routine where they fire
everyone conservative and keep everybody
on the left okay time for some things I
like and then some things I hate and
then the big idea so things I like we've
been doing old Disney movies this week
and so this is one of my favorites for
some reason it really is annoying
there's some Disney movies that are not
available on Amazon Prime you have to
order the old DVDs like doesn't he only
releases these every so often lady in
the is one of these this one came
out in 50s and lady in the is just
great it's just it's it's a terrific
film it's it's really clever there are
certain things in it that you don't
understand when you're a kid watching it
like ladies owners are named Jim dear
and darling and the reason that they are
called Jim dear and darling is not
because that's their actual manged
because that's what they call each other
and the dog doesn't understand their
actual names so it's all very charming
and it this isn't a lot of the stuff
about the Disney films that that's
really great is they work on two levels
they work when you're a kid because
they're really enjoyable and fun and
then when you're adult they also work is
there a bunch of jokes that if you're a
kid you're just not gonna get it's a
really really charming lovely film and
again all the old films are about
heroism and self-sacrifice and
sacrificing yourself for your family
that's that's really what all of the old
Disney films are about lady in the
tramps about that too here's some of the
preview
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is a preview
of the motion picture event soon to be
seen in this theater we would like to
show you and tell you something about
Walt Disney's Lady and the
it's his happiest motion picture a story
about dogs open your heart and build
some glowing memories as Walt Disney
takes you into that wonderful world you
always hoped did exist and never knew
for sure until now the world of dogs
there the old previews are so many one
who's really owned the dog love Sonya or
just wanted a dog this picture is yours
heart and soul right now those jumping
with a lot of the old Disney movies
beutel's and they're a bunch of people
who complain about the racial
stereotyping in the old Disney movies so
like there's in this movie there's a
scene where Lady and the
they're having spaghetti together you
see in the preview and there's a guy who
owns an Italian restaurant he comes down
he's basically just an Italian
stereotype okay if you really think that
that created massive anti Italian
sentiment it's because you're stupid
okay in the 1950s yes there was racism
yes there were people who hated each
other based on ethnic identity that's
true but if you really think that lady
in the was the source of that is
because you're dumb it's the same sort
of people who think that the name
Washington Redskins leads people to hate
Indians hate Native Americans really
really stupid so okay other things that
I like so this is a pretty spectacular
story Harrison Ford punch Ryan Gosling
and that in and of itself is just
amazing
you just have to love that and then he
explained why he punched Ryan Gosling he
said we were just doing a fight scene
and you know it just happened what was
funny was when it was over they brought
ice for my face and Harrison pushed me
out of the way this is Gosling and stuck
his fist in the ice I asked him the
other day where he got his sense of
humor from was did his mother his father
he said Sears and he didn't have much
time to shop around so he just had to
grab one and get out you know he's tough
he's been an inspiration to everyone
everyone who's doing push-ups and taking
an interest in their fitness and Gosling
said look at it this way you just got
hit by Indiana Jones and then Ford was
asked about it he said I punched Ryan
Gosling in the face and then he said
Ryan Gosling space was where it should
not have been his job was to be out of
range of the punch my job was also to
make sure I pulled the punch but we were
moving and the camera was moving so I
had to be aware of the angles of the
camera to make the punch look good you
know I
about a hundred punches in the shooting
of it and I only hit him once and he was
asked so should it be he be grateful and
Ford said I've pointed that out and he
said the one that did connect that's one
hundred percent as foes didn't know I
mean I suppose it's 90 percent his fault
and the person said that's very and then
Ford finishes generous of me and and
then the guy said he said he went to his
dressing room with a bottle of scotch
and Ford said I did he said then poured
him a glass and then walked out with the
bottle and Ford said yeah what's he
effing expect the whole bottle yeah I
figured one drink would fix it that was
enough awesome I love it and then he
calls him a Mouseketeer pretty amazing
he says he was fun to work with I like
him a lot he's a smart guy I mean he's
an effing Mouseketeer he's been doing
this since he was six years old or
something he knows what he's doing
Harrison Florida man ah all the Harrison
Ford just awesome
I think they should remake Blade Runner
but they should not have Ryan Gosling in
it at all she just be old Harrison Ford
being Harrison Ford like just having a
camera follow that guy around would be
incredible apparently he's supposed to
be really great to the staff on set also
he's one of the nicest guys in Hollywood
from what people say okay um a time for
a thing that I hate and then we'll get
to the big idea so Steve minuchin
apparently really really likes living on
the public dime ABC News reported last
night Treasury secretary Steve minuchin
requested a government jet to take him
and his newlywed wife on their honeymoon
early this summer he was worth 300
million dollars or something like that
Stephen engine minuchin allegedly asked
for an Air Force jet which according to
an air force spokesman cost $25,000 per
hour to operate to take him and his
bride Lewis Linton a multi destination
honeymoon which included Scotland France
and Italy that's insane
he is worth 300 million dollars and he
wanted taxpayers to pay for his flight
okay if you serious mega action right
there from Steve minuchin you don't get
to complain about Barack Obama wasting
lots of money on vacations and then say
it's okay when Trump does the same or NC
venusian does the same all these people
who want to live off a largesse of the
government it's really gross it's really
gross and this is why the founders
actually many of them favor the idea of
having wealthy men in government because
it was supposed to be public service not
the public serving you but apparently no
longer man that's so gauche there were
300 million bucks and you can't just get
you can't just charter a plane
ridiculous okay
time for the big idea so on Thursdays we
talk about just a big idea that gives
you background that you need to know so
today excuse me we're gonna do the
history of immigration okay because I
think people get this wrong so Steve ban
and said in his interview on 60 minutes
and America was built on its citizens it
wasn't built on immigration this is a
rather stupid dichotomy okay a lot of
the immigrants a lot of the citizens who
came here were immigrants in fact
virtually all of them were immigrants a
huge percentage of people who entered
the United States during the 19th
century were immigrants because the idea
was that people were needed to fill the
continent that was the idea that was
manifest destiny idea that America was
destined to take over the continent and
we needed more people to do it
immigration in the United States was
basically wide open until the late 19th
century and it was only curtailed with
the growth of the power of the federal
government the only the first serious
federal regulation of immigration began
in 1875 a hundred years after the
founding of the country with laws
directed toward preventing the entry of
prostitutes and convicts there was
concern about cultural assimilation and
real worries about undercutting the
price of labor right just the same as a
lot of the worries today that's what
started the 1882 Chinese immigration
laws that stopped the the Chinese from
immigrating some of that was you know
phobia a lot of it was concerns about
the price of labor going going down
because of an influx of labor in 1885
Congress banned the importation of all
contract labor so you couldn't just
import people and hire them to a
contract so where did the immigrants
come from this is one of the big
questions because the changing
demographics of the country are largely
due to immigration from 1820 to 1930 4.5
million Irish people came to the United
States during the 19th century 5 million
Germans came into the United States as
well between 1880 and 1920 two million
Jews entered the United States overall
during that period 1880 to 1920 20
million new people entered the country
in 1924 largely as a backlash to Jewish
immigration Congress passed a law
restricting entry to 2% of the 1890
population for particular groups so if
there were a hundred thousand Jews who
entered in 1890 then only 2,000 Jews
could enter now that was the that was
the idea behind this immigration bill
and was supposed to sort of freeze in
place the levels of immigration that
were entering the country from
particular other countries meant to
crack down on the Eastern European Jew
in flux as well as the influxes from
Asia it actually banned outright
immigration of Asians and Arabs there
one of the things that's it's kind of
unpleasant to mention about the
Immigration Act of 1924 but it's true is
that one of the reasons for the ban on
immigration was eugenics there are a lot
of people who thought that this was
somehow degrading the cultural stott not
just the cultural the genetic stock of
the United States and so you couldn't
have all these stupid foreigners coming
in here and making people dumb it was
almost an all right approach to
immigration the biggest change to
immigration actually did not come though
until 1965 in 1965 we had the the
Immigration and Nationality Act this was
pushed by Ted Kennedy this is what Ann
Coulter talks about a lot it banned
quotas based on nationality and allowed
Americans to sponsor their relatives so
by banning the quotas based on
nationality you got a huge influx of
people coming in from Latin America and
from third-world countries as of 1970
there were only nine million Hispanics
in the United States today there are 60
million the migration policy institute
says this the law placed an annual cap
of one hundred and seventy thousand
visas for immigrants from the eastern
hemisphere with no single country
allowed more than 20,000 visas and for
the first time established a cap of
120,000 visas for immigrants from the
Western Hemisphere three-quarters of
admissions were reserved for those
arriving in family categories immediate
relatives were exempt from the caps this
was the thing right so if you had a lot
of immigrants from Latin America and
Central America and there were lots of
them during the 1930s 40s and 50s they
were now allowed to do family
reunification and bring in their entire
families they were not subject to the
caps 24% of all family visas were
assigned to siblings of US citizens in
1976 the 20,000 per country limit was
applied to the Western Hemisphere and
then in 1978 there was a worldwide quota
also in that same year in 1960 well
around that same time in 1964 the
government killed the bracero program
which is a work permit program instead
what you had was as a reaction a lot of
people sponsoring the influx of their
their relatives into the country so you
do see a major demographic shift in the
nature of people who are coming into the
country if you look at u.s. immigrant
population by world region of birth from
1960 to 2013 what you see is that the
americas moved from being approximately
15 to 20 percent of the immigrants in
1960 to being well over 50% of all of
the immigrants in the United States
by 2013 it's a major shift it's a major
shift originally in 1960 more than 75%
of all immigrants in the United States
in 1960 were from Europe today that
number is about 12% so you see a massive
shift in demographics okay that does not
mean that people who want to restrict
immigration are doing so based on racism
there are good cultural reasons you know
if you let's say you have a baseline
cultural test and it says do you believe
X Y & Z and people fail that test they
don't get in that's a different thing
than saying we just don't want brown
people here which is what the left says
that immigration restriction is wants to
say to me the only two reasons to have
any sort of restrictions on immigration
our cost to the government if you're
living off of welfare if you're taking
public benefits or you refuse to
culturally assimilate to the United
States those are the only two real
reasons I don't believe the nonsense
about undercutting the price of Labor
that's the same argument you can make
about a minimum wage rate could say that
we just want to restrict the labor
supply I'm not for restricting labor
supplies it undercuts the economic
growth of a country okay so there you go
there's a little background about the
history of immigration it is not true
that we have always that we've never had
emigration restriction that's not true
and it's also not true that all of the
people who made the country great or
quote-unquote citizens who were born
here and came over on the Mayflower
yeah it's just not true either all right
so we'll be back here tomorrow to recap
how it goes over at Berkeley tonight if
you want to watch my speech at Berkeley
go over to daily wire.com we are going
to be embedding a live stream so you can
check it out over there full-on coverage
and it should be lots of fun and
hopefully nobody gets hurt I mean really
people who are coming I hope and pray
you come for an actual honest discussion
but given the preparations the PD are
making that seems probably a little bit
of wishful thinking on my part
all right well we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]